(audience applauding)
- We're back y'all.
From coast to coast, the sun's coming out.
The weather is beautiful
and we are promising,
to help you get out and
about in all the cities
that make up this great nation.
This is Spring Forward USA.
(audience cheering)
(bright upbeat music)
♪ Spring Forward USA ♪
(audience applauding)
For today's job, we head
to a city in the Northeast,
known as the Cradle of Liberty,
as the Home of Fenway Park,
and for a university,
where lots of wicked
smart people graduated.
I am talking about Boston, I love Boston.
(crowd applauding)
Usually we hook up with
our friend, the travel mom,
for our Spring Forward segments,
but she's well traveling,
so that's ironic.
So we have another very good
friend on the show helping out.
Lawrence Zarian is in the heart of it all,
along with Maria Sanson in
the streets here in Boston
(indistinct) today.
What's up y'all?
- Hey, Kelly, how you doing?
So we're getting this party started today.
Where else but the Boston
Tea Party Ships and Museum
because there is so much history here LZ
where we are standing right now.
This is where the actual
Boston Tea Party took
place nearly 250 years ago.
- [Kelly] Oh yeah,
- we are surrounded by
these full scale replicas
of the 18th century ships.
You've got the Beaver and Eleanor.
There are live actors that
you can interact with.
And my favorite part you guys right here,
LZ got to check it out,
you go on the ship,
and you actually throw the tea overboard.
So he was literally spilling
the tea in our Boston Harbor.
(Lawrence laughs)
He's very good at that,
sort of.
(Kelly laughs)
- You looked very athletic, I feel.
So Lawrence, what have
you been doing out there?
- You know what, I've been keeping busy.
Number one, I've been reunited
with my friend Maria Sanson,
we've known each other-
- So thank you for that.
- We've known each other
for a really long time.
Number two, I've been
staying outta trouble.
- No.
- Lying.
- And number three, you know what I did?
I had some fun and went
to the Freedom Trail.
It is this 2.5 mile historic walk
through some of Boston's
most historic landmarks.
From Boston Common, Paul Revere's house,
and you know what I loved?
I loved the Massachusetts Statehouse
with the famous golden dome.
- Gorgeous.
- That was super fun,
everybody should do that.
- Yeah, it's got the famous scaffolding
right in front of it right now,
it's amazing.
(Kelly laughing)
That was amazing.
- You heard that.
It's very old.
- I know, that's what I
love about Boston, though.
It's so beautiful, and I grew up in Texas
where nothing is like that
old, it's not that good.
It looks like you're in Europe,
like if you're from Texas.
So Lawrence, so have you gotten
a taste of the local flavor?
- You know what, actually I have.
Now did you know, Kelly, that Boston
is the home to America's
oldest restaurant?
It is called the Union Oyster House,
and what I love about it is when you walk
into this restaurant, you are
stepping back into history.
The stalls and the oyster bar are actually
in its original locations.
And for me personally,
what I loved, I got to sit
on John F. Kennedy's favorite booth.
- [Maria] That's so cool.
- That was awesome.
- I love oysters, my mouth is watering.
So wait, is there anywhere
else that we should know about
if we go there?
- Oh, you know what I stumbled upon?
I stumbled upon Faneuil Hall.
It is this great little location,
it's been around since 1742.
They've got amazing shops,
delicious restaurants
but also what they have is
they have this brand new
interactive, dinosaur exhibit,
it's called Dino Safari.
And everybody should come
here and bring the kids.
They have actually 30
life sized dinosaurs,
and real actual relics.
(Maria groans)
And I thought that Maria and I were old.
- Speak for yourself.
I'm a young lady.
(Kelly laughing)
- You gotta see these
relics and the dinosaurs.
- My son would actually
love that, he's so bad.
But that exhibits here
through the summertime,
all the way through September,
so plenty of time to check it out.
- Oh, my kids would freak out over that.
Well, it looks like y'all are
living it up in the Northeast.
I'm so glad y'all got reunited,
what are you doing Lawrence?
- Hold on Kelly, I've got
one more thing, Kelly.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- As you know, I'm a slave to fashion,
and when you are on Boston,
you have a little cheddar.
- Oh my God.
- And you wear your lobster sweater.
- Wicked good.
- Wicked smile.
- I love that the entire interview,
you have been looking
forward to that moment,
I love you so much.
- It is the big reveal.
- Thank you Lawrence,
thank you Maria.
- Thanks Kelly.
(audience cheering)
- I love him, so I wonder if anyone here
would be at all interested
in trip to Boston, anyone?
(audience applauding)
We are sending someone in this audience
on a three night trip to
Boston's iconic luxury hotel,
the Fairmont Copley Plaza.
You will experience elegant accommodations
in the Fairmont gold suite, br, br, br.
Breakfast and or (indistinct)
in the Fairmont gold lounge,
exclusive for gold guests.
And you'll also get airfare provided
by Greater Boston Convention
and Visitors Bureau.
So let's say who it's gonna be.
Darren, can you cue the lights?
(audience applauding)
(upbeat drum beats)
(bass guitar music)
(audience cheering)
(Kelly laughing)
(audience clapping)
I love that for whatever
reason, it was kind of dimly.
It was like a dim
spotlight, and I was like,
"I think it's you," I
was like, "I don't know."
So wait, what's your
name, where are you from?
- I am Trish, and I'm
from Lincoln, Nebraska.
- Lincoln, Nebraska, I love your haircut.
(audience cheering)
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] It's so cute.
- Yeah.
- Have you ever been to Boston?
- [Trish] No.
- Oh my God, it's awesome,
you're gonna love it.
- Very excited.
- Oh, my kids, I'm gonna have to take 'em
to that dinosaur thing.
Well, have a wicked time.
- Thank you very much.
- See that you are there, so clever.